what was it about this character in
particular that you were like yes I want
to do the comic book thing it came up as
an idea actually before I even met with
Kevin Feige and then Scott's a
journalist who was in here earlier today
said you make a great doctor story Jimmy
talk to you anyway that as well they
might not know but who's dr. stranger so
he introduced the idea and so crazy it
was crazy but and there are the people
in the group that I was talking with
then is a good idea this was very much
about occultism and East's yeah mr.
Deason missus isn't meeting Western
logic and I'd had a bit of that
crossover in my own life when I was a
teenager I was lucky enough to teach in
a Tibetan Buddhist monastery oh wow that
was a mind-blowing experience for her
you know white clip from Europe so that
opened my mind and and heart and all the
rest of it to an incredible other side
of life what I love so much I'm a huge
comic book fans of seeing the Steve
Ditko art in there where it just is so
close to what the comic book looked like
what did that feel like for you getting
to put that up on the big screen it was
the starting point for the whole movie I
wanted to go we talked about going full
Ditko by the end of the movie you know
and once you commit to doing something
that bizarre it really frees you up for
the other sequences in the movie to be
as bold as possible the art it's just I
mean it was so amazing for you seeing it
for the first time on the big screen did
it magically kind of look like what
you'd envisioned in your head look much
more than I thought yeah yeah it was
much more than I thought especially the
stuff I was I wasn't in actually because
I haven't dealt with those scenes I knew
what they were about but that they
sometimes to that farm they were brave
and very graphic wonderful you know
let's not waste it and just feel
rewarded by being sort of mind blown and
you really needed a nice cup of
chamomile tea to sort of calm me down
because it's a real riot that you go
through that once they touch your third
eye you know you really go into this
crazy ride up you know it's worth
definitely seen again if you could
relive one moment and loop from the eye
of agamotto what moment from your life
what if you know literally here now
listen to I'm so happy with where I am
in my life and even if I wasn't I think
a way of being happy or content is just
being present while the future may hold
great treats I'd love them
some of them to be surprises I always
wanted to go back and visit jinkies can
someone oh I don't know why do I get to
do it differently yeah you can do it
differently my childhood the whole thing
the whole thing look quite like using it
for sort of cooking purposes to be
honest well you know you could sort of
leave some food ingredients and then
sort of switch on the argument so then
you might get a nice little roast dinner
and then you can eat it and then maybe
when you're fat and then you kind of you
don't want to do the dishes you can turn
it back and it kind of sort of goes back
again
you